And fermented organic beef sticks be the cause of my mold or high micotoxins.
Yeah, so anything that can grow mold in it, then could then produce micotoxins.
So, and then follow up how about cashews, walnuts, pumpkin seeds.
These are things I eat and my wife doesn't. My wife has zero micotoxins, and I don't.
This is the person's trying to discern where they got the micotoxins from.
Was it from foods that I eat and my wife doesn't.
This is the kind of discovery I want you to guys to be thinking about.
So yes, so what are most common things?
So understand, micotoxins are from molds that are growing either in our house on organic matter
and then it's giving off micotoxins and then we breed those micotoxins in or food.
It's growing in food and then it's producing micotoxins and then we eat that food and work
consuming those micotoxins.
So each micotoxin are that list of that micotoxin lab test.
It lists the most common source food sources of that particular micotoxin.
Are cashews a source of micotoxin?
Well, maybe walnuts, maybe pumpkin seeds?
I don't know.
I have to look back on that list of the micotoxins that this person is who asked this question,
what they showed high and see if they're listed in there.
But in reality, not everybody probably, not every food product is listed in that micotox report.
So anything is a possibility, but it really has to do with the moisture content of that thing
and could organic beef sticks grow mold?
Yeah, they can if they're old.
I guess we just don't know.
I mean, that's the very difficult part about trying to discern that is that some things you can't,
you can't necessarily test for and some things you can't know.
So stay away from those things.
I know I have some practitioner friends that they themselves had really high micotoxins.
They literally will not eat peanuts.
Peas are probably the most common food source of micotoxins.
Grains would fall into the next list.
I think cashews, walnuts and pumpkin seeds will be weighed out on the list,
and maybe organic beef sticks, but that would be weighed out on the list.
So I don't know anything is possible, but I would say barely low chance on all these things.